-This Friday, June 19th,
is Juneteenth,
a holiday that celebrates
the end of slavery
in the United States.
But not everyone
is familiar with it.
So, here is "Late Night" write
Amber Ruffin
with answers to frequently asked
Juneteenth questions.
-There's been a lot of tal
about Juneteenth
the last couple weeks.
But some people have
never heard of it before,
and they have questions
about it
that they feel
embarrassed to ask.
So, I let some folks mail me
their questions anonymously,
and I'm gonna answer them
right now.
Okay.
Question number one.
"What is Juneteenth?"
Okay. Great question.
Juneteenth is the anniversar
of June 19th, 1865.
That's the day the last
American slaves were freed -
otherwise known as "the last
good day in Black history.
No, I'm just kidding
a little bit.
It's the day we celebrate
our freedom,
and see how far
we've come.
Okay. Next question.
"Didn't the
Emancipation Proclamation
free the slaves
in 1863?
Why, then, is Juneteenth based
on a day on 1865?"
Glad you caught that. Yes.
After slaves had been freed,
and the Civil War was over
some people in Texas
still had slaves,
and would not
let them go.
They held on to them
for an extra 2 1/2 years.
And then,
they were arrested
for brazenly
disobeying the law.
Just kidding.
Slave owners have never
been punished.
Okay. Next question.
"How do you
celebrate Juneteenth?"
Great.
Okay, now, usually,
Juneteenth is celebrated
during, like, a block party,
with fun music and good food
where a little girl sings
"Life Ev'ry Voice And Sing,"
while I shout at her
"You had better get
that song sung, baby."
But this year,
because of COVID,
we're all gonna celebrate
by watching Alicia Keys
and John Legend battle it ou
on "Versus."
That's just a real
answer for you.
Google it.
Okay.
"If I'm White,
can I celebrate Juneteenth?"
Yes.
White people can
celebrate Juneteenth.
But you got to do it
by going like this --
"Oh, no. My slaves.
My precious slaves."
No, I'm just kidding.
You celebrate it
by being thankful
that your Black
friends and family
are free to be
whatever they want to be.
Then, you do your best
to make that statement true.
No costumes, please.
Okay.
"If Juneteenth falls
on a weekend,
do we get
that Monday off, too?"
Okay, now, I don't have
the authority
to make that decision, but I'm
gonna say, "Yes. Definitely.
Okay. Next question.
"Does the holiday Juneteenth
make up for all the --"
No. No.
We're not gonna
finish that question.
The answer is "no,"
no matter what
the end of it was.
Okay.
"Why am I only hearing
about Juneteenth now?"
Okay.
Ask your Black friends.
Just kidding.
I can tell by your questio
you don't have any.
But you should make some.
We're fun, and you might
get invited to a block party
Just make sure not to celebrat
it by wearing a costume.
Okay.
"Is this gonna become
one of those holidays
that's just an excuse
to hold car sales?"
No. Please don't
cheapen it like that.
Although, I do need
a new car,
'cause if think I'm getting back
on the subway anytime soon
you have lost
your dang mind.
So, maybe.
Okay.
"So, now that Juneteenth
is an official holiday,
what else can we do
to address systemic racism?"
Okay. Hire Black people.
Defund the police.
Call out White supremacy.
Fight the power. Be anti-racist.
And most importantly,
stop asking Black people
how you can address
systemic racism.
I don't have time
to answer all your questions
I have to go
buy a car.